Union européenne poursuit les agriculteurs
devant la justice.
Elle
demande de poursuivre les agriculteurs qui luttent
contre la concurrence déloyale.
La Commission européenne avec Thierry Breton,
a confirmé que les importations de poulets
ukrainiens continueront pendant 1 an
avec les mêmes quantités qu'aujourd'hui,
soient trois-cent-mille tonnes.
Quel média vous parle de tout cela ?
Et pendant ce temps,
l'Europe fait 1 chèque de 50
milliards d'euros pour l'Ukraine.
À qui profite vraiment le crime ?
Le milliardaire Yuri kossuk, avec la société mhp
qui détient 80% du poulet ukrainien,
mhp, c'est trois-cent-mille tonnes d'huile de tournesol
et sept-cent-mille tonnes de poulet.
60% du chiffre d'affaires de mhp est réalisé à l'export
et depuis deux-mille-vingt-deux,
mhp a doublé ses exportations vers l'Union européenne.
Car depuis 2 ans,
c'est devenu plus facile pour l'Ukraine d'exporter.
À ce propos,
Yuri kossuk disait toute sa reconnaissance au soutien
économique européen
qui, grâce aux accords de libre-échange,
avaient mon permis de relever les quota
et de supprimer les droits de douane.
Poulet qui sont vendus à moins de €2 le kilo à la
distribution française.
Et malgré la situation,
Thierry Breton, le commissaire européen,
demande aussi la poursuite en justice des agriculteurs
luttant contre la concurrence des loyales.
La prochaine étape sera le poulet aux
hormones en provenance du Brésil.
On marche sur la tête,
cela devient du n'importe quoi,
c'est 1 évidence.
L'Europe cherche à mettre
tous les pays en guerre civile
où nous entraîner dans la guerre contre la Russie.
L'Europe aura ainsi la docilité de sa Population,
les médias vont soutenir les dirigeants
pour nous amener à la guerre,
dans le conflit, tout le monde va se taire.
La vraie question maintenant, qui se pose,
quand allons-nous prendre conscience
que l'on ne peut pas abandonner les agriculteurs ?
Nous devons marcher à côté d'eux.
Les agriculteurs sont la terre,
ils sont notre survie.
Sans nous, ils ne sont rien et sans eux,
nous sommes encore moins que rien.
Qu'est-ce qu'on attend pour nous mettre debout
face à cette fausse réalité ?
Et vous, qu'en pensez-vous ?